[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime
daily opening statements in the case of
a tennessee man
accused of stabbing his parents to death
dismembering their bodies
even trying to cook his mother's severed
head on thanksgiving weekend
plus minnesota prosecutors are trying to
expose
some of the officers involved with
george floyd's death
as having troubled past and gridiron
great joe montana fights off an intruder
in his malibu home law and crime daily
covers court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin let's begin
with the tennessee murder trial of joel
guy
jr he's accused of stabbing his father
and mother to death and then scattering
his parents dismembered body parts
around the house
his mother's head was on the stove his
father's hands
on the bathroom floor their torsos were
said to be soaking
in barrels full of acid the defendant
faces a possible life sentence with a
shot at parole
after 51 years prosecutors say it was a
violent bloody stabbing which ended with
this gruesome disposition
of the family's body parts you will
learn that
in the master bedroom of their home
plastic sheeting was placed on the floor
and these
blue plastic bins were placed on the
sheeting
the killer put lisa's body parts
in one and he put jill seniors in the
other
and then he covered them with a
corrosive substance
and left them there to liquefy
into some sort of
diabolical stew of human remains
and then the killer took lisa's head
and carried it downstairs
and took it into the kitchen
he got out a stock pot placed her head
in the pot
filled it with liquid carried it over to
the stove
covered it turned on the stove
and left it there to cook that's how it
ended but prosecutors say
this is what led up to those disgusting
discoveries
lisa had both of her arms removed
from her torso at the shoulder both of
her legs
were cut off below the knee
her right hand was severed
from her arm and the killer cut off her
head
you will hear testimony from a forensic
anthropologist who will tell you
that her head was
basically broken from a part of the
spine called the
atlas there was a blunt force trauma
applied to her neck before her head was
severed
from her from her spine after the limbs
of these
people were removed the killer placed
them
separately into two
45 gallon blue stir light containers
terry austin is here now with a look at
just some of the key evidence the
prosecution showed the jury during those
opening statements terry
aaron among the prosecution evidence is
a store receipt from walmart and several
images taken
from store security cameras authorities
say defendant was buying
alcohol and peroxide at 3 35
pm on november 26th prosecutors say
one view shows the defendant making a
purchase the camera
is directly above the checkout notice
the bandage
on his right hand also there's an image
of the defendant
leaving the store prosecutors say the
picture shows
a bandage victim lisa guy made purchases
earlier the same day placing the timing
of the killings prosecutors say
on the saturday afternoon just after
thanksgiving
prosecutors made the connection between
those purchases
and the evidence photos from the crime
scene where bottles of alcohol
and peroxide along with a walmart
receipt were discovered by authorities
the pile of evidence flagged in these
photos shows
how much critical evidence the police
found just
in this small area thanks terry and
there's even more chilling evidence
prosecutors say the police recovered
handwritten notes from the defendant
himself which they say
show him planning the details of the
killings
get rid of bodies inside house
there and my dna already there one note
reads
it continues flush chunks down toilet
not garbage disposal and it goes on from
there
other notes suggest prosecutors say that
the defendant was also trying to figure
out who would benefit
from his parents insurance policies and
now to brian buckmeyer with the defense
opening statement brian
erin the defense started with an
introduction and a thank you to the jury
then gave an opening which lasted less
than a minute and a half
here is most of it our criminal justice
system
is one of the probably the best one in
the world and what makes it
so great is that we have citizens
who are willing to come to court
especially during a pandemic during a
time like this
when they come to court spend the week
listening to the proof and making a
decision
and another strong part of our
constitutional
criminal process is that that decision
has to be
made beyond the reasonable doubt
and that reasonable doubt can come from
witnesses it can come from physical
evidence
it can come from cross-examination and
we just
ask you and know that you will listen to
everything
very closely listening for the
reasonable doubt and making your
decision at the end of the case
again i want to thank you for being here
this is a difficult time to try a case
difficult time to do anything and we
really need you
and you've come forward and we really
appreciate that
thank you okay brian so the evidence
seems rather solid for the prosecution
in this case did the defense do the
right thing there by focusing on a
reminder about the burden of proof
and saying very little more so
stylistically speaking let's get this
off the bat aaron i
am not one of those defense attorneys
who do what this defense return does not
do what's called a non-opening opening
it's an opening where you're not really
giving any facts you're not pointing to
anything the jury should be looking at
you're just saying please follow the
rules of the judge and come to a
conclusion
i personally think it was incorrect i
know others will disagree with me i
think he could have pointed out to a few
key facts for example there's no
eyewitness who said that my client
committed this crime
there's going to be no such evidence
that points directly to him it's all
circumstantial
i think he could have given a little bit
more and it would have been a lot better
just a little bit more may have gone
many many more miles in the minds of the
jurors it would give them something to
say
i'm not looking out for this and i
wonder why interesting tactic there so
terry
the state's opening was somewhat soft
with a case with facts as heinous as
these
was that tone by the state appropriate
in your opinion
no and that's exactly what i was
thinking this is
probably one of the most heinous crimes
i've ever heard
and she gets an a plus on giving all of
the details
but in terms of her tone she was flat
she was callous
and if you really want to get the
jewelry on your side to make sure that
they know
someone has to get punished for this
crime she should have really had more
tone
more intonation more outright
indignation and she didn't she just
basically
told the fact she even said something
about a diabolical stew of human remains
and i noticed
the defendant took notes at that point
so it's very strange that she was very
flat
possibly could have hit the nail on the
head a little bit more good analysis
there from terry and brian and still
ahead here on law and crime daily
witnesses take the stand in the trial of
joel guy jr
did this defendant kill his parents
dismember their bodies
and even cook his mother's head on the
stove as prosecutors allege
and later on lawyers in minnesota ask a
judge to admit evidence involving the
pass of three of the officers
accused of playing a role in the alleged
murder of george floyd
we break down the court documents when
law and crime daily returns
[Music]
you're looking at body camera video from
police officers entering the home of
joel guy jr
note that notice the pot on the stove
that appears to be where prosecutors say
the defendant was cooking the severed
head
of his own mother in her own home the
ghastly scenes recorded by the officers
who entered the home were on display for
the jury during the first day of
testimony
in this murder prosecution it wasn't
just the sites but other sensory
evidence that law enforcement officers
testified to in court
so the garage door comes up detective
mccord is in front of me
i'm behind detective mccord the other
two officers are behind me
as we enter the garage you can feel an
intense heat
coming out of the garage area we go up
to the the interior garage door
and if you're facing in the garage the
interior garage door would have been to
our right
detective mccord announces knox county
sheriff's office
and at that point he pushes the interior
door
open when the interior door comes open
we step into the residence there's some
chemicals sitting in the floor as soon
as you step in
and then we begin to clear the residence
okay when you're clearing a residence
describe to the members of jury what
you're trying to achieve sir
we're at what we're trying to achieve to
see if mr and mrs guy are okay
due to the fact they didn't come to the
door you've got groceries sitting in the
floor and the back door knobs obviously
missing at that point we continue
through turn come down the foyer where
the
groceries are lying in the floor i look
to my right
i see long guns lying out on the dining
room table
i actually feel a tingling on my
forehead from the time that i entered
the home
as we continue on and start up the steps
the the heat is more intense it's
it seems to be getting hotter the
horrible scene continued to unfold those
officers testified and prosecutors also
called the defendant's sister
who testified as to a possible motive
the victims were about to retire and
they were prepared to cut their son the
defendant
off from support
he was going to be retiring he well they
had been talking about it for a while
but he had sent a group message to
we have a family group message in it um
so that was on november
17th that he finally got word that his
house had sold and they had signed the
documents
and that they needed to be out of the
home by december
13th so but they have had
had the house up for sale for quite some
time okay
and were you aware of lisa's plans to
retire uh yes
she was excited about retiring and just
spending her time they were madly in
love so just spending time with each
other
does she make any statements to you
about her
intentions with respect to the support
of her son the defendant she did on one
of my trips back home in october
um she dad and i were talking out in the
garage and
she had stated that they were going to
retire
and it was time for joe michael to stand
on his own two feet he was an adult
okay so terry i thought that last piece
of testimony was a bit of a bombshell
there and there were some other
witnesses that did mention it during
proffers but the prosecution didn't
really dig into it any further with the
witness we just watched was that a
mistake in your opinion
i do think it was a mistake i mean it's
clear that money was the motive here but
you want to impress upon the jury as the
prosecutor
what the motive is and you want to get
into some sort of details
here the prosecutor just said you know
what was said and
and clearly it was stated that the joel
guy jr was going to be cut out of the
will and not have any
money and so that was the motive there
but
they didn't get any to in the uh detail
and so i do think that was a mistake
here you got to take advantage when you
can
yeah look there's ways you can ask a
similar question a similar way before
you wind up with a defense objection
from somebody like brian buckmeyer so
brian
the defense didn't cross-examine that
witness should the defense
have at least asked a few questions
there or was it best to get out of that
testimony quickly
the thing that makes most sense to me
aaron is this might have already been
decided prior to this witness testifying
because once this witness starts to say
well this person stated to me or said to
me that's hearsay that's an out-of-court
statement said for the truth of matter
asserted so the judge may have had a
carve out
just so they can try to improve that
motive aspect and the defense is
probably not trying to open that door by
asking more questions it's the only
thing that really makes sense to me yeah
there were many proffers for these
witnesses and i think that's a good
explanation under the rules of evidence
as to exactly
why this probably rolled out the way it
did the key being once you get that into
evidence you can argue it all day long
on summation coming up on law and crime
daily a judge is getting involved in the
police death
of eric garner in new york city also we
discuss damaging documents filed against
three of the former
police officers in minneapolis who are
heading to trial over the death of
george floyd
law and crime daily is back in just a
[Music]
moment
a manhattan judge has ordered an inquiry
into the 2014 death of eric garner
the ruling was a response to a lawsuit
filed by garner's relatives
his mother gwen carr alleged a police
cover-up the judicial inquiry will look
into
several facets of garner's very public
death including the alleged lack of
medical care provided to him after
police put him in a choke hold
the new york state legislature this
summer passed a law banning police choke
holds
named in memory of eric garner minnesota
authorities have filed seven pages of
court papers asking a judge to allow
them to tell a jury what george floyd's
alleged murderers
have hiding in their pasts records show
that derek chauvin the officer who
pressed his knee into floyd's neck
had used similar techniques on other
suspects eight times
dating back to 2014. prosecutors say the
other incidents prushovan knew what he
was doing to floyd
and went way beyond the acceptable use
of force co-defendant j
alexander king is accused of one
incident involving unreasonable
restraint
while co-defendant total is accused of
several incidents including manipulating
witnesses
and falsifying police reports so brian
prosecutors are saying that
tao didn't stop what was happening to
floyd because his track record shows he
hated writing reports is that a solid
enough reason to get these police
internal records entered into evidence
in a criminal trial
it's going to come down to about
character evidence and knowledge what
they're trying to prove
and i think if they as they did in their
motions show that this is an mo
type of situation they will be able to
get it in and it's going to be really
damaging for these defendants
exactly i mean when you get into
evidence piling up like this terry this
gets tricky but as to derek chauvin and
alexander king prosecutors are saying
a pattern of unreasonable restraints
did not lead to deaths and that chauvin
and king should have known that if they
kept it up a death would occur
is that legally sound as well in your
opinion actually
it sort of defies logic if you ask me i
mean if they've had these
other restraints that did not lead to
death maybe they could not determine
whether or not
this particular restraint would lead to
death i do think however that both
restraints by
chauvin and king were excessive and they
should
have known that if they continued to
restrain him particularly when he
looked as though he was in trouble that
that could possibly lead to death
some of those documents are very
detailed they go into the histories and
whatnot saying well in this case you
only use the restraint for
half the time or less than half the time
as you did in the george floyd case
terry so
in other words in the floyd case you
just went beyond what you knew was safe
in the past and therefore
that's how we believe you have motive or
some other knowledge that something bad
is going to happen
well that's exactly right so the fact
that chauvin has used these restraints
before so many times and his records
showed that he should have known that it
could have caused death when it went
over the amount of time that he used
those restraints in the past
and when we come back right here on law
and crime daily updates in the
investigation into the shooting death of
brianna taylor
ballistics reports and police records
raised new questions
about precisely who filed fired the
bullet
which struck one of the responding
officers was it briana taylor's
boyfriend as authorities have led us to
believe
[Music]
former nfl quarterback joe montana and
his wife jennifer montana
stopped the kidnapping of their
grandchild in their own house
police say montana and his wife
confronted a woman who entered their
malibu home the woman allegedly picked
up
the montana's nine-month-old grandchild
from a playpen
after a tussle the famous football star
and his wife pried the child out of the
woman's arms
the woman fled to a nearby home and now
faces kidnapping and burglary charges
and now to several updates in the police
shooting of briana taylor a kentucky
state police ballistics report is
conflicting with the local district
attorney's assertion that taylor's
boyfriend shot sergeant john mattingly
d-a daniel cameron claimed friendly fire
had been ruled out
because the officers carried 40 caliber
handguns
while walker carried a nine millimeter
one of walker's attorneys obtained a
police report however
which says former detective hankinson
had also been
issued a nine millimeter weapon the
ballistics report suggests the source of
the bullet
which struck the officer could not be
determined
a kentucky representative who sponsored
brianna's law which bans no knock
warrants
has been arrested alongside her daughter
at a louisville protest
representative attica scott was charged
with rioting in the first degree along
with other
counts a rioting charge is a class d
felony the same level
of felony officer brett hankinson is
accused of committing when he fired into
neighboring apartments
when taylor was killed police body
camera footage obtained by vice news the
night of briana taylor's death
seems to corroborate some of her
boyfriend kenneth walker's testimony
vice reports the footage shows officers
appearing to break several department
policies
the footage shows the officers were
involved in the deadly raid
they were mingling together rather than
being separated
and also paired with an escort which is
what was supposed to happen
according to standard police procedure
the video also reveals that
the officer indicted by a grand jury for
firing into neighboring apartments was
even allowed back into the active scene
so terry
so many updates happening in this case
the video is trickling out now
what's your assessment when you've got
procedures being violated what does that
say
well it's very concerning and part of
the reason it's so concerning is that it
took so long for this information to
come out
this happened in march we're now in what
are we almost in october
and we're finding that first they said
there were no
body cams and now it turns out there
were multiple body cams
and the fact that these police officers
were
mixing and mingling with the scene
hankinson cosgrove and mattingly
should have had nothing to do with the
scene they should not have walked onto
the premises they shouldn't have gone to
the hospital they're supposed to be
separated and so this is very concerning
and it makes you feel
as though there is a cover-up so brian
what do you make of the forensics with
the guns and whatnot so they're saying
well one's got a 40 caliber one's got a
nine millimeter and then whoops wait a
minute
the police also have a nine millimeter
that throws another wrench into things
that we didn't expect
i think for the most part however though
this doesn't really go into the
garbage calculus that the attorney
general camera was trying to make in
terms of self-defense
but it does go directly to the
credibility of the investigating
officers as well as the attorney general
because if you're presenting a case to
the grand jury and it is inconclusive as
to where or
who fired that gun that should at least
at the very least
reach a threshold that a grand jury can
indict on higher charges
that is a problem a major one okay so
brian just very quickly though we also
know that it was the boyfriend that is
said to have fired the first shot
according to him and officers do have a
legal right to defend themselves against
that
yes and so the officers can shoot back
at kenneth walker but again
if you shoot back at the person you're
trying to defend yourself from and you
hit a third person
that's manslaughter you can't claim
self-defense that's where it gets tricky
brian and terry great analysis here on
long crime daily we'll see you back here
next time for our discussion about
justice in america
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network today
[Music]
you